okay so I know what you guys are saying
right off the bat Rob Neymar's not from
Atlantis in the MCU he's from a whole
different place and that's true to a
degree but by the end of this video I
think you're gonna basically say the
same thing that I am which is yeah like
either they're gonna discover Atlantis
or they're gonna ReDiscover Atlantis but
whatever the case is that's where Namor
is going to end up taking residence
assuming they don't kill him and I don't
think they will because he's another
mutant they're adding to the MCU so he's
basically going to become a main star in
the MCU later on down the line so let's
explain Atlantis let's talk about
Neymar's Kingdom right because when the
time comes we inevitably get there you
guys want to be experts on him so here's
the thing in Marvel Comics Atlantis has
a very very lengthy history but it also
doesn't at the same time so the entire
nature behind Atlantis goes back to
really the age of the celestials before
that in Marvel Comics you do have some
stories some more Fantastic Four stories
you do have things like Tales of
Atlantis but one of the things that
Marvel does is they have stories that
contradict other stories and so it's
hard to know what's accurate and what's
not the only real dish distinctive thing
that we know for sure when it came to
Atlantis was basically everything from
the great cataclysm or at least around
the time of the great cataclysm going
forward so the way this works in Marvel
Comics and it's a little bit different
from the MCU although we still don't
know the full history of the celestial
so there's a lot to be explored there in
the early days of Earth the celestials
had visited the planet like they'd done
so many others and conducted an
experiment on the early days of humanity
they were technically called The
Wanderers so you might refer to them as
the missing link between primate man and
modern man but it was basically a small
subsect of humanity one group was turned
into into eternals one group was turned
into deviance and then the third group
had their genes modified so that at some
point in time they would basically
manifest I.E the basis or the origin
behind the mutant population of Marvel
Comics now again we don't necessarily
know exactly how that'll translate in
the MCU we know the eternals are a
little bit different but we don't even
really know their full history or even
if what they were told was true by the
celestials because Irish and the judge
kinda seems like a dick so the thing
about this is that in the early days
when the celestials visited Earth of
course creating the eternals the
deviants and then modifying the genes of
Baseline humans the eternals were
basically Angelic right they were
everything that you would consider to be
the peak of human potential meaning they
had the ability to tap into Cosmic
energies they could fly they had super
strength speed all that kind of stuff
very superman-esque in terms of their
abilities but with the celestials
knowing that the deviants due to their
destabilized genes and their lack of
intelligence would ultimately fall prey
to human nature which is to say to wage
war against others the deviants would
eventually try to conquer the Earth and
so to ensure that didn't happen the
celestials tasked the eternals with
basically keeping the Earth protected
and keeping the deviants at Bay the
eternals didn't do that they had their
own Civil War which led to Titan which
led to like Thanos and Eros and all that
kind of stuff but because of the fact
that the eternals are basically derelict
in their duties when the celestials
arrived a second time on Earth to
basically check up on their experiment
they realized that the deviants had
conquered the Earth the eternals had
ignored the charter that was given to
them and Humanity was for the most part
turned into slaves and so what this day
did is it led to the deviants attacking
the celestials believing the celestials
were encroaching on their territory the
celestials of course obliterated pretty
much all the deviants pushed them to the
brink of Extinction but during that time
they sunk Atlantis in What's called the
Great cataclysm now having said all of
that for Atlantis itself it was kind of
a neutral territory right that where you
had places like Lumeria which was the
capital city of the deviance where you
had Olympia which was the capital city
of the eternals not to be confused with
the Greek god Capital Olympus where you
had these different places that were
ruled by these two groups for the most
part Atlantis was neutral because it was
a trading Hub if you lived in a part of
a world and you had things that you
needed Atlantis was where you went and
one of the things that I do want to
establish the deviance did not conquer
the entirety of the world there were
still sections of it where you had free
men and because Atlantis was neutral due
to the fact that their king would
literally capture and kill anybody who
tried to start war in Atlantis which is
ironic because the King was a warmonger
and always trying to expand the sphere
of Atlantis against deviants and the
eternals because that would happen
nobody wanted to be a party to it right
nobody wanted to be captured or killed
and so it was basically kind of like
hands off right do your thing and then
when you leave the war's back on again
right that kind of a situation but once
Atlantis sunk there were two major
things that happened the first is that
not every citizen not every human or
even person who was in Atlantis died
that some of those individuals survived
and in fact some of them remained within
the capital city of Atlantis itself what
this meant is that when it sunk and went
underwater the various you know
Sorcerers and so on within Atlantis
basically cast magical spells that
allowed them to breathe underwater over
time their bodies began to evolve and
they ultimately took on the kind of
blue-skinned form that you see in Marvel
Comics from time to time when it comes
to the atlanteans and they basically
resided there the other thing that
happened is that during the Great
cataclysm chunks of Atlantis broke off
which basically meant that some of those
individuals who were in The Kingdom of
Atlantis actually ended up taking up
residence in some of the surrounding
territories the two most important when
it comes to that are Avalon and Ruda and
the reason why that matters is because
in Avalon you basically had a woman who
gave birth to a daughter named Morgan
eventually learned the art of magic
sorcery so on and so forth and she went
on to become one of the most powerful
practitioners of sorcery and Marvel
Comics often times rivaling doctor
strange and using the name Morgan lefaye
in terms of Ruda that was ridiculously
important because on that island was a
guy named miradan who was actually an
enemy of Morgan for a period of time but
miradan ended up leaving Ruda traveling
to England joining King Arthur and
changing his name to Merlin so that's
kind of where where you know why those
two little things are are important in
that way but for the larger part and the
bigger discussion here if we really want
to invoke the MCU and talk about the
nature of uh of of name or the
Submariner one of the things that we
learned recently that we covered in
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four is
that in Antarctica under vostok Lake is
actually a tribe of atlanteans and when
we ended up learning about that what
Marvel did is they came back and they
said oh okay so the way this worked is
atlanteans didn't just flee to the
surrounding islands of Atlantis that
somehow survived that what other
atlanteans did is they actually took off
to thuria and thuria is basically the
general name given for the Earth as it
existed at the time which was basically
just Pangea right just a giant land mass
that kind of surrounded Atlantis but by
modern standards you would call it like
Europe Asia the Americas that kind of a
thing and so what it did is it basically
led to these individual humans who
survived kind of traveling around and
sort of interbreeding with humanity and
then just kind of losing their Atlantean
Heritage but for some groups they
totally left Atlantis right they
literally just fled they ran as fast as
they could during the Great cataclysm
and they took up residents in other
parts of the world but because of the
fact that they were so isolated and they
were so well hidden for hundreds of
thousands of years nobody even knew they
existed more so than that they didn't
know the surface world was still intact
they didn't know that there were still
land masses where people dwelled and
like Humanity was building and growing
that's why during Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run during the prime
element storyline Susan storm discovers
the atlanteans down there and they seem
incredibly unaware of everything that's
going on because they lived in isolation
and they weren't the only ones right
like the war of the four cities like
they weren't the only ones that were
there there were other Atlantean tribes
like that that did that out in the world
and that brings us to this discussion
about name where the Submariner in the
MCU if I'm a betting man right I'd bet
all the money in my pockets to all the
money in your pockets which I currently
have none in my pockets that what's
gonna happen here is that name of the
Submariner is going to be an Atlantean
or descended from an Atlantean tribe
that takes place or exists out there in
that part of the world but they're
literally a branch off from the greater
Atlantean group and that he may very
well be like the rightful heir to the
throne of Atlantis or something along
those lines the reason why I say this is
because as most of you guys know you go
back and you look at the the ending of
Iron Man 2 right you got the map behind
Nick Fury there's a giant just like
Beacon out there in the Atlantic Ocean
exactly where Atlantis would be now it
could be the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is ignoring that they're just not really
worried about that anymore it's like
well that's that's old hat and we've
changed things since then or it could be
that they're borrowing a page out of
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four run
where the tribe of Neymar the Submariner
and their part of the world was so well
hidden nobody knew they existed not even
Shield knew they existed and that kind
of makes sense right like a giant land
mass under the Atlantic Ocean if your
shield and you have all the world's
intelligence at your disposal you can
probably spot it pretty easily right
especially if there's like beans moving
around there and they have blood and
Warm Bodies maybe just like literally
heat vision on a super deep scale would
tell you that right but when it comes to
somewhere like South America there's
tons of people moving around there and
so it would effectively be almost
impossible to discern the difference
between people moving on land and people
moving under the ground and so as a
result of that they could stay
exceedingly well hidden now again we
don't know how far reaching this is
going to be I'm just kind of throwing
this Theory out there just kind of
giving you guys my my opinion on it and
so having not seen black panther 2
that's what I think is going to happen
the name of the Submariner is going to
be a guy that rule rules a part of the
world where you have what are in effect
atlanteans but they are part of what is
a larger tribe they simply just don't
know it either that or Atlantis doesn't
exist in the traditional sense they're
ignoring Iron Man 2 but this Kingdom
that that Namor rules is basically
Atlantis by a different name that's
entirely possible as well and honestly
that might make more sense but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end let me know what you
think down in the comments section thank
you all for watching I will catch you
all later peace